good afternoon ladies and gentlemen my
name is he and hayden smith now I'd like
to welcome you to this BAFTA Film Awards
session on music if you took all the
work that our guests have composed over
the years and put it together it it it
creates an incredible body of work in
many different genres I'd like to
introduce first of all Terence Blanchard
on my meteorite he's a five-time Grammy
winning composer from turn band he's
worked with the director Spike Lee since
his second feature school days in 1988
and has been the composer of the
majority of schools and documentaries
for Spike Lee since jungle fever in 1991
he's also worked on films as diverse as
yves Baio dark blue barbershop and Red
Tails and his score for black clansmen
is his first BAFTA nomination also here
with his first BAFTA nomination is
Nicolas brittle before he stole fur if
Beale Street could talk directed by
Barry Jenkins it's his second
collaboration with Barry after moonlight
in 2016
he's a Steinway artist and founding
member of la dance project and amongst
his other scores
there's battle of the sexes and also
adamak eyes satires the big short and
most recently vice and then to my far
right we have we have Marc Shaiman much
just discovered this is actually his
second after nomination after 1993
Sleepless in Seattle he began his career
working in Saturday Night Live and
produced a fruitful collaboration with
Bette Midler working in as musical
arranger and also as a co-producer and
many of the films the many films he's
worked on include misery in an act
hairspray and LBJ and of course Mary
Poppins Returns which he's been
nominated for a BAFTA for Terence I want
to start with you first of all and the
score for Black Klansmen it's
interesting to hear an electric guitar
leading the way in some of the music and
it's from your band
the e collective could you talk about
the early conversations you had with
Spike Lee about the music that you were
going to produce for the film
well I mean me and Spike have been
working together form for a number of
years so the the conversations are very
minimal you know basically he told me he
said he wanted to have an R&B band
inside of the orchestra but when I got
the first cut of the film and I started
to look at it you know and I saw John
David Washington walking to the scene
with that afro and the leather jacket I
for some reason my mind went to Jimi
Hendrix playing the national anthem at
Woodstock and in the 70s you know for
the young folks in the room every
version of the national anthem was very
pristine back then so they hear that
distorted guitar playing the national
anthem was a very kind of revolutionary
thing and but also for me it was a very
patriotic thing and with spikes movies
he's always trying to deal with humanity
and trying to talk about in an indirect
way and sometimes in a direct way how
we're all you know Americans and how we
all deserve protections and equal and
same rights under the law so that sound
of the electric guitar was more of a
liberating thing for me and I thought it
was appropriate for the film because of
what the subject matter was just
thinking about your other work with
Spike watching black Klansmen again the
other day as well as the band that the
score has a scope and a grand year that
took me back to Malcolm X and also your
score for the documentary when the
levees broke I'm glad you mentioned the
orchestra working with the band can you
talk about working with the orchestra
and the larger sound that you created
well it's interesting that you say that
because that's exactly what spike told
me when he called you know he said this
is gonna be Malcolm X all over again you
know in terms of the scope of the score
so he arias at the table for me in terms
of the the the the sonic backdrop for
the film so I knew you know right away
that we want to have large or one thing
we didn't have was a choir that's we
Malcolm expoweed in evidence and with
spikes films you know he gives me a lot
of room so you know they're moments
where it's interesting because we were
having this conversation we buried the
editor of the other day they always cut
pretty tight you know there's not much
room but they they over the years
they've been learning to leave a little
space for me and some some sections you
know yeah just a little things so I've
gotten to the point now where they're
moments you know where I'll try to try
to be reserved and how I score things
and wait for those moments where I know
spike wants the the the orchestra to
kind of take over and like I said he
gives me a lot of room to do that and
it's a lot of fun man when you're
sitting in your room by yourself and
it's just you in the film because I have
to be honest about how I'm feeling about
the story and how I relate to what I'm
seeing on screen and the cool thing
about working with Spike we're kind of
like in sync as far as how we see things
you know it took me a minute honestly
though because he doesn't like
underscoring his main thing is that he
wants to have very melodic stuff happen
on the underneath his scenes and
sometimes it could be problematic
because there some scenes that have a
lot of important dialogue that's
important to pushing a story forward
right so I had to learn how to kind of
stretch melodies and use certain types
of instruments for orchestration to make
sure that they don't get in the way of
the dialogue but in doing that it's
created this kind of style that's
uniquely spikes thing and with that like
I said earlier with them with the
moments in time where I get a chance to
kind of let the orchestra breathe I
always have to be careful actually with
that because spike loves music so so
much we're always telling I know this is
gonna sound weird for composer but we
always tell him to turn the music down
you know I mean come he loves it so much
he's always mixing it real hot but but
it was a great experience you know but
the main thing about any of these movies
is the story itself you know the story
itself was so powerful it really told me
what it needed for the film and that's
been my journey in this business and not
trying to impose
my will on a film but to try to sit back
and let the film tell me what it needs
let's stay with story Nicolas working
from a novel by James Baldwin and when
seen the film you you have some text by
James Baldwin at the beginning him one
of the things he says is Beale Street is
a loud Street it's left to the reader to
discern the meaning of the beating of
the drums just thinking about rhythm in
the film and you have Trish's voice over
which much of which is Baldwin's own
words Baldwin has that very specific
musicality to to his writing just
wondering from your perspective as the
composer on the film about the dialogue
between the voiceover and and your music
and the discussions that you had with
Mary about that that's a good question I
haven't had that question before I think
that there's definitely this question of
you know when you're adapting something
from a book how much do you take from
the book what is the influence of the
book what's the influence you know on
the film how does that translate one of
the things with working with Barry
though is that he is so much my guide in
this so I read the book and I read the
script and you know early on Barry and I
would have these conversations before
he'd shot the film actually where he
would sort of come to me and say you
know early instincts of what the movie
might sound like and his the first
things he said to me were he said he was
imagining the sound of brass and horns
and the you know the quote that you're
referring to as that the idea of like
drums and percussion and interesting
that there's actually in the score there
is rhythm and the relationship of where
music comes in absolutely but there
really isn't much in the way of drums I
think there actually there are drums
where the scene where Titian fani are
first making love there's a hypnotic
kind of a rhythm that we were looking
for and there actually is underneath the
music there there is a kick drum that I
sort of ran through a low pass filter to
give it almost like a like it's more of
a soft kind of attack
and there is a percussion there's a
percussive kind of rhythm in a lot of
the low bass pulsing that I put
throughout the score that I would run
through actually some guitar filters and
give it kind of an angry sort of a
feeling but you know the question of how
things interact with dialog versus music
is just a constant conversation I would
really echo it turns was saying in the
sense that the movie tells you what it
needs and I think that's really the
crucial thing you know them you know
where we're there to serve the movie and
Barry and I kind of go on this journey
where we actually don't really know what
the sound of the movie is gonna be until
until we're done in a way you know the
movie is exactly like parents saying
it's telling us things and we're
responding to that so you know early on
I start doing these experiments I'll
show them to Barry we both sit in the
room together and you know watch the
movie together and try things out and I
think it is about that feeling of
honesty where you have to be so sort of
honest and open with yourself it's it's
not about writing a piece of music that
I loved and sang here's here's this
piece of music I need this to be here
you know everything I write or give to
Barry I want to love but it has to be
right for the movie and it has to be
right for Barry and I think ultimately
that's that's the goal and there is this
sort of mystical alchemy of
what works in a particular place so you
know whether music goes in a certain
scene or not we we have no idea we'll
try things out you know there are scenes
that have no music and then we'll say
what if we put score here you know like
maybe and sometimes we're like
absolutely not Wow we try that that
didn't work but but we're sort of
finding that rhythm I think as we go and
and it really changes over the course of
the months you know what what we decide
to do idea the rhythm fascinates me with
this film because the anger engendered
by the injustice that lies at the heart
of the story notwithstanding the music
adds to this sense almost of a reverie
not quite a dream yet something more
ambient than that there is definitely a
sense I think and part of that is I
think Barry's overall aesthetic with
this film in particular is it's a very
which aesthetic you know every Barry
Letts every department bring sort of
their most to him and you know I think
everything from the the costumes and the
colors and the performances it is this
very rich aesthetic feeling and there is
certainly you know in the way that I
think music interacts there is this
dreamlike kind of nature to how you're
supposed to experience it where you have
moments of you know really we were going
for a moments of extreme joy and and and
love and then there are the moments like
where you see Daniel telling Fani of his
unjust imprisonment and we are going
into the dart that that the hellish
nature of injustice and the musical
texture there is actually completely
different what what we did was we we had
for many months we'd explore really just
that feeling of love and beauty and then
it was in April I think of last year
that Barry came to New York and we were
working together and all those moments
of injustice had no music initially so
if you think about the the dreamlike
nature that was in love and then an
injustice it was harsh reality but it
wasn't feeling enough for us in some way
it felt it we you know Barry has this
feeling that he's looking for which is
we don't want to tell you how to feel we
actually are trying to convey the actual
experience of certain feelings so we had
this idea of what if I took some of the
stems of the cellos in the scenes where
you're making where they were making
love for the first time and I bent them
and distorted them and Barry would say
how do we how do we break this music how
do we harm it in a way so that the music
is undergoing its own you know
destruction in the same way that the
world is trying to harm their love and
it just worked it felt like this
horrific sound that was almost coming up
through the floorboards as Daniel is
talking to Fani and you know that became
its own dark kind of a dream space mark
that want to stay with the the dichotomy
of dream and reality with mary poppins
returns the first time i saw the film
seeing that the perfect synthesis of the
songs the music and performances story i
just where do you begin with this so
let's start with the songs in the
storyline of how they developed in
tandem and then the incidental music
around that oh yeah ah Scott my co
lyricist and me and David McGee the
screenwriter and Rob Marshall the
director and his producing and life
partner John DeLuca
we met in a hotel up on the Upper East
Side around four months it's not like a
no Harvey Weinstein kind of way we we
gathered there to create the plot when
Scott and I entered the picture they had
already come up with the idea that it
was going to take place in the 30s
what's um what 25 years after the first
movie the books were written to take
place in the 30s but Walt Disney felt
1910 was a more colorful bright light
time to place it but we loved the
darkness of the 30s and the depression
or you called it the slump and the idea
that Michael Banks is now a recent
widower they had that idea but once we
came in then we really started at the
beginning and he created an original
musical which means that you'd really
have to collaborate this we're all just
thinking what if this happened and you
know and then we would read all the
Travers books there's eight Mary Poppins
books which I didn't know and I was a
Mary Poppins fanatic I mean I was four
years old when the movie came out and
the movie and that soundtrack record are
everything to me but I didn't know there
were all those books maybe it's because
I'm illiterate but uh so we just went
through all the adventures that are in
the books because they're they're very
episodic and we had to create a plot
that made use of those episodes and what
the lesson of the episode was how that
would mirror our-our plot and it just
was weaving back and forth and that was
one of those glorious times I've ever
had in the collaboration especially
because all we had to do was talk about
that's easy then Scott and I then we
took then it was Christmas and then we
went into our writing studio after the
New Year's and then Scott and I sat and
only sang the song that we always start
all projects with which is terrified
with fear paralyzed with fear
always in this case so ever somewhere
because we knew we were going to be
compared to the greatest score song
score ever written for an original movie
me also loving a win kosslyn was the
original musical supervisor Orchestrator
adapter of the music from the first
movie this man also Godley so we knew we
were like god how do you even begin to
write when you know you're gonna get
punched in the face no matter you know
what then in the middle of writing the
songs they cast lin-manuel Miranda so
now you know you're you're writing for
the preeminent writer of his generation
who everyone's gonna say well why isn't
he writing it so by the time we got to
the piano I was but then you know we
just had to start writing and we
realized by writing we could show our
love and I write a love letter and a
thank-you note to the Sherman Brothers
in Erwin kostol and everyone else who
made the first movie and say this is
what you taught us I mean I literally
that record that is it for me that's my
schooling so you know we made a movie
that it's for me it's like if you have a
great teacher that you loved who really
taught you something that really meant
something to you and that you really use
in your life or you or your craft for
your career and I got to go back to them
and say here's what you taught me do you
like it I mean
and luckily Richard Sherman is still
alive and at 90 years old still has
darker hair than me I don't know how he
does that but he was able to see it and
and just said the most wonderful things
to us repeatedly because I looked him
right in the eye when he was saying it
looking for like you know in a poker
game is called the towel or someone
someone does something that you know oh
they're bullshitting but he really
seemed to love what we did he said you
feel like you pick up the baton and you
ran the next you know timer so that's
everything the fact that I even got to
sit in a room with Richard Sherman
besides the fact that he was saying
these wonderful things and I got him to
ask him all the questions I ever wanted
to ask since I was four years old has
any of this answered the question yeah
no no it kind of leads
to the next thing I was very curious
about with the film and I think is what
works so beautiful about the film I
think a less or a more safe option in a
way would have been to have more
referencing of the original film and for
me one of the joys of watching it is
just the odd little from refrain every
now and again coming to the incidental
meet it just it just the way that you
wrote around the main song did you
create the songs first and then sort of
yeah and then from but I knew that my
job I knew that Rob and Marc Platt the
producer had hired us knowing I'd be
scoring and that they got this kind of
package deal and so I knew these songs
could very well become the foundation of
the score but you know a score can't
just be the melody of a song but if you
listen to my film scores over the years
you'll see that like Sarah are with me
for better or for worse I mean I've had
a lyric in mind for every theme I've
ever written for a movie in this case
they actually are on screen and it was
when we wrote the song that Mary Poppins
things first in our film called can you
imagine that which was the fourth
attempt to write a song for that slot
they kept hearing on the songs that we
were writing oh that's very good but
remember it's the first time Mary
Poppins is singing on screen in 54 years
you think it's good enough huh and also
this very idea of a theme where Rob said
that you know I love this song there's
one song that was really there for
months they even did screen tests on it
and he said you know it's funny everyone
loves a song and can sing it except for
the title the title was the less catchy
part of the song he said so go back one
more time and and we've been trying to
write in the style of the early dance
bands of the of Britain in the early 30s
we thought Mary Poppins knows where
she's landed but this time we just oh
screw that let's just go for the musical
cedar sound and we wrote the song and
then after we I demoed that Scott said
now play it like film score before you
send off the demo send a demo of you
also playing it in a film score fashion
and when I did that and manipulated the
chords and the texture and the rhythm it
really did take on this weather like a
melancholy grandeur that seemed to match
where the movie was going so once we had
that moment we felt like okay we know
where we're going and that was months
and months before filming recording and
I feel like I'm talking too much
something I'd like to know from all
three of you about the idea of
universality with the music
perhaps Nicholas we'll start with you I
know people have asked you before about
why isn't this a jazz score yeah it's
it's a Haarlem in that era and it's
Baldwin to me it's a score that works
brilliantly but one of the reasons I
think it works so well is because of the
dialogue with the tracks the songs that
are used in the film that locate it
within a specific moment in time but
then you move ain't in the score could
work through time could you talk a
little bit about that oh absolutely I
think you know there there is a
connection and I think they're always
there always has to be some sort of a
connection even if it's not obvious at
first where you know for example in this
case when Berry was talking to me about
you know the sound of what is the sound
of brass and horns and how would I
experiment with that you know the film
said in the 1970s in Harlem Barry and I
did talk about jazz and the sound of
sort of 20th century jazz and in the
film there is incredible you know
incredible examples of 20th century jazz
I mean you hear blue and green on a
record player you know you hear you know
I wish I knew John Coltrane so I think
you know my starting point though is
always that I don't always want to hear
what I'm seeing and I think in any score
that's kind of what I was you know
talking a little bit about before with
this idea of like what is the sound of a
movie I mean there are so almost like
infinite sounds I think a movie could
have and I think something that I love
is sort of trying to find something that
feels like it's part of the movie but
maybe you didn't expect it in some way
so you know can you hear something
slightly different than what you're
seeing source music can always you know
is incredible at giving you a sense of
time in place with Beale Street you know
I actually started with this idea of
brass
and jazz kind of like seventh chords and
then I was saying to myself what if I
just used the idea of like extended jazz
harmonies as a starting point for
writing actually more of like a
through-composed classical piece of
music so there's a there's a string
piece that you see when when Titian fire
in a restaurant early in the film and I
actually approached it saying what if I
was writing like early 19th century
chamber music but I was using you know I
was all cellos actually but I was using
these sort of jazz harmonies as a
starting point so the that sound of like
let's say seventh chords and ninth
chords and eleventh chords is throughout
the film which to me feels like there's
a like a spiritual connection with with
20th century jazz and yet the overt
style I was trying to go for I think
something that was just its own creature
like I'm not even sure sometimes what
the genre is it sometimes feels
classical sometimes it feels like some
other I don't even know what you know I
think honestly I don't I often don't
even like to think in terms of genres
because I think it holds you back like
music itself is just this continuum of
sounds different you know different
styles different countries everything
there's almost like algorithms as well
you know maybe they'll flat the six here
maybe the rhythm is this you know but
but they're just choices you know it's
all just these notes and you know
rhythms and chords and so I think that
we we kind of you know it's like I was
saying we find this sound and it it is
related to the picture but a lot of that
is almost I think subconscious how we
how we get there sorry please when I
watched the movie the second the music
started I was reminded and this is a
compliment I'm not saying it's like this
great records Ben Webster with strings
great jazz saxophone player he made a
few records that are so seductive and
the string charts are so fantastic that
fifties New York Ralph burns did most of
them and that's what it's you know so I
thought I thought of jazz immediately
but so beautifully
placed in this like semi classical yeah
oh I hated you from the second the movie
star
so good
and so great without the needing to have
3000 notes and runs like you know like
me like it's so I mean the word
simplistic seems like a terrible word
but the simplicity the elegant
simplicity and the score I the hatred is
and I will add I'm in awe to be sitting
here with both of you guys so I am very
and very honored towards a moment ago
Nicholas was talking about genre a very
enjoyable element of black clansmen is
the film itself feels at times like a
genre mashup you're never quite sure
where you are so it's it's great because
it unsettles you which it should but
likewise with the music I find it very
interesting that this dialogue between
the songs and and your score you're not
just dealing with one type of music
you've got the music the Tran listens to
and you've got a variety of music could
you talk about that and how you sort of
interacted with that well well the he
hit on it right he hit it on the head
you know being a composer man listen
Stravinsky was one of my favorite guys
to steal from you know and she really
took on daring folklore but he he used
that as a seasoning you know for what he
expanded on right so which spikes films
one of the things that spiking myself
always talked about well we used to talk
about is that we wanted the score always
to have this universal feeling to it we
didn't want the score to be so genre
specific because we wanted everybody to
feel like they could come to the film
and Spike you know like a lot of
directors he will use source material to
give you exactly what the film where the
film is you know and with black clansmen
there was a much need for me to go into
those realms specifically we had the R&B
band the electric band inside of the
orchestra just enough to give you a
little bit of grooves to give you
electric guitar and some electric piano
the
say okay those are the elements from
that period but we use them just as that
just as colors you know not just to say
that you know we're trying to play like
Earth Wind and Fire from the 70s or any
of those R&B bands that were very
popular at the time but to have enough
of that there to mix with the source of
material that's there to make sure that
everything kind of weaves in and out of
themselves in an elegant manner right
and it's actually pretty cool because
like he was talking about the harmony
it's the same thing with black Klansman
you know you have these armed I have
this electronic band playing there but I
didn't use jazz home and using you know
the melody itself is using like just
fifths moving back you know in major
thirds right and it's more of like a
power kind of sound without power
elements to them you know what I mean
because I was trying to write something
strong for Rhonda the main character
harmonically and melodically very
simplistic but very strong but out
without beating you over the head with
it so my thought was okay well now that
I have this thing that moves back and
forth like this let me use these other
elements just as you know just like
seizing and you know just like any other
thing when you're trying to mix elements
together and I thought it came out very
well it worked well for the film and
it's one of those things man where we
were talking about it earlier he was
talking about it early where you start
off with that idea and you go you know a
little further with this you know maybe
I can use the guitar actually here I
didn't think about using the guitar here
but let's try it and let's see what
happens here and then all of a sudden
those elements become characters you
know they become parts of the of the
storyline you know and it adds to the
uniqueness of the film very much like
the characters are they actors
themselves you know you know there's
there's a talking to Kevin Willmott who
was the writer one or one of the things
that I learned from them is that you
know it's a period piece but they took a
lot of Liberty liberties with the with
with the dialogue inserting certain
things that kind of brought the story
forward
you know I mean so they are actually
doing the same thing but the script that
we were doing with the music you know I
learned I didn't know that initially but
I learned later on and to me that's the
fun of what it is that we do because I
think if we try to go so far back in the
past and make things so johner specific
it's only gonna reach a certain number
of people who actually understand where
that comes from you know what I mean
there's you know it's it's kind of like
they're a bunch of kids right now who
have no idea about that stuff you know
what I mean they have no clue so I'm not
trying to exclude them from the
experience by saying that oh this has to
be directly from the 70s no we want
everybody takes experience it we want
people who've never even heard that
music you know in in in the far-off
lands and some countries that we can't
even pronounce you know to sit down and
watch the movie and go okay I can
understand what's going on with the
story because the score itself has a you
know it has taken a universal approach
to telling the story but there is still
that wonderful thing with it where as I
said because of the whole idea of the
film itself shifting tone a great deal
well yeah I mean well there's always
elements of that stuff we did like you
know with the with the Klan man we use
some really really tight snares and some
of those snares are so tight I was
worried about those guys hitting them
too hard because we wanted to really get
a really crisp kind of edgy sound you
know we did the same thing in miracle at
st. Anna man well where when we saw the
US soldiers we had the big field drums I
had a nice round fat sound and with the
Germans we used these really tight
snares that had like a really crisp kind
of sound and so we went back to that for
for this film and it worked rather well
you know and then there are moments and
times as a subtle shift in the scene
whether you have the Klan initiation
which cuts between that and then Harry
Belafonte you know given the speech at
the at the college with the Student
Union so they're minimal things that I
tried to do there you know cuz I didn't
want it to be on the head like he was
telling you earlier it's not about
telling you oh you're watching the Klan
now it's not that it's about feeling
like he was saying about feeling that
you're in a
going back and forth feeling that the
cold steel nests the clan and in feeling
the the the despondent a heartbreak of
being in the room with hair battle
finally telling the story of the young
kid who was lynched so there are subtle
things that I try to do with just the
orchestration that you shouldn't notice
musically but you should definitely feel
as you watching the scene mark again
talking about universality and you
touched on it a moment ago of not
necessarily wanting to go back to that
particular era but I'm just curious with
the musical with changing tastes amongst
audiences of how you tap into a classic
tradition of the Me's gone perhaps even
the American Songbook but also finding
that appeal with modern audiences or is
that a dangerous thing to do and you
have to find the voice that the film
needs yeah I was very happy that no one
said you know how do you can you
contemporize this especially when
lin-manuel was cast I was like oh you
know what are they gonna you know they
kept saying we've got to make sure you
deliver lin-manuel you got to deliver
lin-manuel scott and i dressed as
midwives then for the rest of the
writing process but you know Mary
Poppins lives in the world of Mary
Poppins and she lives on Cherry Tree
Lane in London and this was London in
1930s and so and it's um and she lives
in a magical musical world the world of
musicals has its own sound like even
like a classic musical like gypsy that
doesn't really sound like what the music
of the 1910 1912 1921
it's just musical theatre sound so
luckily no one was like that and that
was that was liberating because almost
opposite of what these guys are saying
about their scores this was one that did
there is a genre that we were in and I
was swimming in a glorious sea of the
genre that's it so John I've been
wanting to write a whole movie score
like this my whole life and I'm sure
there are directors who have walked away
from
their scoring sessions of mine and
thought why is the schmuck scoring my
movie like it's a [ __ ] Mary Poppins
sequel so now I finally had a director
saying schmuck score my movie deal it's
a Mary Poppins sequel I'm sorry I said
[ __ ] so I mean you know and not only me
but the orchestra and the orchestrators
we were all delirious delirious with joy
that we were getting to right and the
nicest compliment that our Gavin that
our conductor when it was all over he
said marked the harm and he's a user
it was just so wonderful to just look at
the score and and for every little note
you know to be able to come up with all
the harmony you want to do it and it's
we so painstakingly think about it it
was the nicest thing someone could have
ever said to me once again I don't
remember the question that's fine
I remember watching in an interview
years ago was with David Lynch and he
talks about the something called the
duck eye moment which is something that
he feels is the heart of the film or
where he knows he's hit that point the
tipping point where it's actually
working with these projects that you
worked on did you have a moment where
you thought I've nailed this I know
exactly where I am Terrence was it just
a process and you always feel like it
Neil until somebody comes into the room
it goes so that's always a hard one um
in my family they know I'm always if I
if I finish a scene and I'm feeling a
little web certain way about it I say
hey come here come here come here come
in here listen to this what do you think
and they'd never want to give me an
answer but that's okay
but you you try to just go by your
feelings your honest feelings I remember
the first time I scored Michael max man
that was a second film I have a school
of my life and I was scared to death
but I had to think about my first
reaction to hearing a speech by Malcolm
and how terrifying it was for me and
that's was the thing that brought the
the opening sequence out of me right so
when I'm watching these films I'm and
I'm going through them
I allowed myself to cry I allowed myself
to laugh I allow myself to go through
all of those emotions and let those
emotions guide me and tell me what to do
you know with this film I knew that the
montage was coming up with the Heather
hire thing and I knew how powerful that
was you know and for me I wanted to
write a piece of music that was not
going to be afraid of screaming to the
world about the outrage of what was
going on in our country so I'll let the
music just just go and and that and and
in the an interesting of the thing about
it was being a jazz musician there's
certain moments you feel like you can't
write what some people will feel so
that's when you bring in great
improvisers you bring in great musicians
who you know can play in the moment and
crew and bring something to it that you
can't and that you won't see because
also I'm always the person that always
feels like you know if I'm sitting in
the room and were to film for eight
weeks sometimes objectivity might go out
the window you know cuz I'm sitting
there focusing on this one scene over
and over and over again so bringing
other musicians and always kind of
brings a freshness to it for me so with
Charles altura man he's been in my band
he's a great guitarist and I know that
this guy you know has a brilliant mind I
said I'm gonna just cut him loose at a
certain point and this one particular
piece who caught blood and soil and let
him go and he knew exactly what the
subject matter was about and he just
took it home from there and it's kind of
interesting because he gave me exactly
what it was that I was looking for but
in his own style and it there's nothing
that I could have written that would
have conveyed the same type of immediacy
I guess is the word or emotion that that
related to the moment right because at a
certain point it's not score in that
particular moment of the film it's not
score it's just pure emotion it's
because unlike some of these other films
this film is relating the period piece
which is a real story to what's going on
in our country right now you know so at
a certain point our
stop scoring the film I just wanted to
write music that conveyed what I knew a
lot of people in our country will feel
and let that play out throughout the end
of the film yeah that question of like
when do you think youyou found the sound
in a way I would I would almost contrast
I think my experience working with Baron
moonlight and Beale Street because in
moonlight when it was pretty early
actually it was I wrote there was a
piece of music that I wrote after
reading the moonlight script because I
felt I felt the moonlight script was
just this beautiful piece of poetry it
was the most beautiful script I've ever
read and I wrote a piece of music called
piano and violin poem I was really like
channeling this idea of poetry I was
like what would it sound like if I was
trying to write a musical poem and so I
wrote I wrote it and I recorded a demo
of it and I send it to Barry and this
was actually I sent it to him right when
they were starting to cut the movie but
I hadn't seen anything and that demo is
littles theme and it's in the movie you
know he just took the recording and he
was like this is this is the sound this
is this is littles POV and in a way
because of the structure of moonlight
which is three chapters but we are
following little as he as he grows up
through his life the connectivity of
that I think once littles name was there
which was pretty early on I think I did
feel like I had connected something
because that you know the film tells you
if you've connected and the structure of
moonlight allowed for you know you could
find something a beginning and then you
were like oh we're gonna evolve this but
this is the this is the the direction
with Beale Street I think I didn't have
that feeling I think I the idea of brass
and horns and this feeling of love but I
think you know for both me and for Barry
we didn't I definitely did not feel like
I had figured it out in any way for a
long time you know I was talking before
about that discovery after quite a few
months of the sound of injustice I think
there were ways forward there were there
were ideas of the direction but Beale
Street deals with many different kinds
of love it deals with this idea of
almost unconditional divine love
romantic love erotic love the love the
parents have for their children so
there's all these different kinds of
love and there's this idea of injustice
and I think that you know for me and for
Barry I think we're
focused on the fact that even moments of
joy contain moments of sadness you know
in a way like every emotion has its own
opposite inside of it and that's what
makes it strong
you know like joy is joy because in a
way it's finite you know this idea of
like it's so special you have to cherish
it even more because it isn't gonna last
forever you know so I think there was
this complexity to what we were going
for that definitely took a lot of time
and a lot of work to feel like we had
hopefully you know arrived near that
mark I wonder if with your work there
are a series of tipping points there's a
composition stage then you know you're
going to be working with the cast and
depending on who gets the roles and also
the choreography of bringing everything
together and I wonder if it is a series
of tipping points or epiphanies that you
have yeah every day there's some version
when you talk about you have to have
such confidence while you're writing
because every choice you make then
you're gonna build something on that so
you have to really feel like alright I'm
sticking with that because that's a deck
of cards that will fall apart I was
reminded it may not be the answer to
your question which I find I'm being not
very good at but when we were recording
the songs you know we pre-recorded all
the songs before they filled we had a
two-month rehearsal period then for two
weeks we recorded the songs even if they
might sing live on set we had everything
recorded and recorded with a full
orchestra which real I was shocked that
Disney would allow but rob was like I
want the full orchestra 85 pieces I was
like but what if we changed things
things are gonna change but not only
that he said to me well here he gave me
like five scenes he wanted me to score
at the pre-record sessions before he had
filmed the movie so this wasn't just
about writing a piece of and when I
don't mean just but this wasn't a moment
of writing something that has a mood or
a feeling this was scoring a scene
specifically there's this scene where
the kite
Michael puts it in the trash and then it
starts to fly on its own and it goes
down the street and it goes through the
park
and the kids run after it and and
Jacqueline Manuel's character tries to
help them and it gets very dangerous and
suddenly out of the dark clouds comes
Mary Poppins this is like a two and a
half minute maybe piece of score Rob I
can't
I need a movie to score he's like oh you
can do it yeah and you're gonna do it
you I really want that there was so I
went home once again on the Christmas
vacation this was a year later and I
start to thinking he is insane and I
can't believe after a lifetime of being
told hurry up less musicians that I'm
gonna record music that will never be
used because how could it possibly fit
what's gonna get filmed so I still wrote
you know and made use of kind of themes
you know like even when the kite is
going it's actually making use the theme
that starts the movie the lin-manuel
sings and then it goes into other things
and I just wrote I just III spoken to my
computer this the dialog and read the
stage directions as with as much emotion
and passion as I could and try to leave
space in between or moved it around once
I started writing well I'll move them a
little but I still thought this isn't
saying God to the sessions and Rob even
said that's wonderful I don't think we
need those four bars there I said well
how do you know just record it anyway
this is all insane anyway he said no I
don't think we need it so we record it
all and it's very long story short sorry
it wasn't everything we recorded that
days in the movie Rob is such a
brilliant emotional technician that he
knows what he wants
and I just can't believe that there's so
many I kind of iconic moments of the
score were recorded before a single keep
those four bars or are they not in there
no they're not in there no you you know
you've been spoiled now you're gonna be
turning up at future projects I said no
no Rob Marshall let me do this this is
this is it was so scary I I wouldn't
wanted to wrap it again there was a very
specific unique but did you mark did you
Mark and the music where things were
happening very much so I mean you know
Rob we were like oh this is when that
will happen
I mean you could hear it in the music
and and I was just happy he liked what I
had brought and I mean there first of
all there's just that is he gonna like
this then is he gonna use it I remember
Nora Ephron Sleepless in Seattle once
our relationship had kind of gotten odd
and at the scoring session we after
finishing a cue she meant that's very
nice mark I just wish there was
somewhere in the movie I could use it
god rest her soul on that now we are
actually out of time sorry no we
actually ended up having a wonderful
friendship we did we really really did
when I found out today that I was a
nominated for BAFTA word for soup was in
Seattle and it's been such a long life
full of so many things that I had
forgotten can you imagine I forgot that
I was nominated for a BAFTA Awards that
is the essence of blase knees I am so
sorry
thank you very much tip after 2 for
organizing this event but most of all
can you please join me in thanking
multi-man mrs. Patel I'm Terence
Blanchard
[Applause]
you